the family of the jogger killed in
Washington DC is praising police were
quickly arresting a murder suspect
Wendy Martinez was stabbed to death on
Tuesday detectives believe it was a
random act of violence the 35 year old
woman had just gotten engaged her fiance
last week chip Reid is out there it's
outside the restaurant where Martinez
who was jogging at the time ran for help
after she was attacked
chip good morning well good morning
Wendy Martinez lived just a couple of
blocks from here and as you can imagine
her death has unnerved many people in
this neighborhood last night many of her
neighbors and friends gathered in a
nearby park to honor her memory and
offer comfort to her family
Wendy Martinez's loved ones say the
quick arrest of a suspect in her murder
has done little to soften their grief
[Music]
her mother Cora urged mourners at a
candlelight vigil last night to live by
her daughter's example my daughter put
up to the last breath
police say they tracked down the man in
this grainy surveillance video Anthony
Crawford in a park Wednesday night about
a mile north of the crime scene the 23
year old is charged with first-degree
murder but his motive is unknown police
don't believe it was a robbery or that
the suspect knew Martinez we will be
taking a look at not only his criminal
past but if he had any mental health
issues or substance abuse issues
Martinez was out running Tuesday night
waiting for the light change when
Crawford allegedly stabbed her seven
times she sought help inside a nearby
Chinese takeout restaurant but the 35
year old collapsed and was later
pronounced dead at the hospital
Martinez's death came seven days after
her fiance Daniel in kPa proposed to her
you know I'm gonna keep her alive
helping her achieve the dream such a
message in copy a said Martinez an avid
runner was trying to qualify for the
Boston Marathon but the South Florida
Natives ultimate goal was to help poor
women in Nicaragua where her parents are
from her younger brother Juan Carlos
called her his role model Cora Martinez
said the week following Wendy's
engagement was the happiest in her
daughter's life she says because of her
Christian faith and the outpouring of
support from the community she feels no
hatred for Wendy's killer I'm sad but at
the same time I never said I have chosen
to forgive and I forgive that person
Cora Martinez said she was with her
daughter last weekend when she bought
her wedding dress but she never imagined
that the next time she would see her
daughter wearing that dress would be at
her funeral Jana
think about the strength that Cora has
to be able to forgive this man yes so
soon after he took her daughter away
from them I've shattered I marveled to
be on it people that can do that when
they are in such pain and such grief and
with every detail of the story I got
where she was engaged just got in the
dress and then to see the video of her
actually running into the store you know
clearly clearly distressed just only one
positive her mother said this was the
best week of her long life short life
there